TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and I'm
very proud to be hosting
"The Developer Show" this week.
Let's skip the song and dance
number, and jump straight
to the show.
First up, ha, the TLDR.
Go beyond just JavaScript APIs,
frameworks, and the mysteries
of CSS to also learn
the tooling that
can mean the difference
between an average web
developer and a
super-productive web developer.
Check out the recently
launched web tooling
and automation course on Udacity
to learn about setting up
your editor, creating powerful
build scripts, live editing,
linting, and all other sorts
of awesome optimizations.
It's now a lot
easier to retrieve
data about an authenticated
user's connections
from their contacts by
using the new People API.
And it's time to
update to HTTP/2,
as Chrome will no
longer support SPDY
starting on May 15th, which is
the anniversary of the HTTP/2
RFC.
Starting in version
49, Chrome for Android
will surface
physical web content,
helping an even larger
audience discover
URLs relevant to their
surroundings via Eddystone
Bluetooth low-energy beacons.
Now is the time to check out
the physical web and what
it can do for your users.
Use Google to rapidly
build backend services
for your mobile app that scale
automatically to meet demand,
automatically synchronize
data across devices,
handle the offline case
gracefully, and send
notifications and messages.
Learn how Hydro Coach rapidly
reached 22 new markets
in this new blog post
on monetization tips
straight from successful
app developers.
It's a great companion
to the no-nonsense guide
to app monetization we recently
mentioned on this show.
Make more money from your
app with in-app payments.
This video on the zen of
monetization with Ido Green
shows you how.
Need an awesome functional
UI testing framework for iOS?
Well, we just
open-sourced the one
that we use for YouTube, Google
Calendar, Google Photos, Google
Translate, and
Google Play Music.
Check out the blog post for more
details and the GitHub link.
The Google Summer of
Code is a global program
focused on bringing more student
developers into open source
software development.
Students work with a mentor
open source organization
on a three-month
programming project
during their break
from university.
If you'd like to be a mentor
organization, follow the link
and submit an application.
If you're a university
researcher working
on the Internet of
Things, we invite
you to participate in this
technology research award
pilot.
It provides selected researchers
with in-kind GIFs of Google
IoT-related technologies,
with the goal
of fostering collaboration
on small-scale experiments
and discovering what you can do
with our software and devices.
As usual, the linked blog
post has a lot more detail.
And that's your TLDR.
Let's see what's
next on the show.
Oh, I get to go find Laurence
Moroney on the set of "Coffee
with a Googler."
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Laurence
Moroney, and I'm here
with Timothy Jordan on this
next episode of "Coffee
with a Googler."
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi,
Timothy, how are you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It doesn't
feel quite right, does it?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
Throw the script away.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So this is
where the magic happens,
although not always
just in this place.
You were saying that you
film throughout the campus
because you really want to give
a peek into the Googleplex,
not just an interview
with the Googlers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Exactly.
So it's like, you know,
Google is a living, breathing
entity it seems sometimes.
We've got great people here.
We've got a fabulous campus
that we get to work on.
And, you know, let's just have
a peek inside of life every day
in Google while having a
10-minute chat with a Googler
over coffee.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
you've interviewed
a lot of amazing
Googlers on the show.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes, I have.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Who have
you not interviewed yet
that you want to
take this opportunity
to invite on the show?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Who's, like,
would be the-- maybe give me
the top three, your
crowning achievements--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well I've
already interviewed you--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --of
"Coffee with a Googler."
LAURENCE MORONEY: --so--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
leave me off the list.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I mean seriously,
I would actually really love
to interview Larry Page.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I would love
Larry to come on the show.
So-- and we can
do it in Seattle.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Remember that Google I/O
where, like, he
just came up and he
talked about the things
that were on his mind,
and then he took questions?
LAURENCE MORONEY: That was--
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That was amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's what
made me want to join Google.
I worked for one of our
competitors at the time,
and I was invited to
the Google I/O Extended.
And I watched the keynote and
I watched Larry take the mic
and, like, talk as he did.
But then the more he talked,
the more awesome it became.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It was amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
Twitter fell silent,
and then Twitter just
went, this guy's awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It was, like,
the most earnest conversation
with a CEO in the tech industry
that I think I've ever seen.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
watched that and I
said, I want to join this
company, and here I am.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Here you are.
OK, that's your number one.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
Larry's number one.
So number two, oh,
I think Vint Cerf.
I'd love to have Vint on.
So Vint once keynoted
at a conference in Korea
that I was a speaker at, so I
got to share a stage with him
for about five minutes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: He's amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
He's incredible.
And the work that he has
done and he continues to do
is really-- it's
because of that that we
can do what we do today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I
would love to have Vint.
And Vint actually made a
comment about a previous show
that he really loved the format.
The third one I'm going
to leave to the viewers
instead of picking it myself.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
if there's-- you know,
we actually did a thing before
where we asked viewers to say,
who would you like
to have us interview,
and two names came up.
One of them was Larry, and the
other one was Colt McAnlis.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And you got Colt?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
We got Colt, yeah.
And Colt was being
Colt. He kind of-- we
swapped seats for the show.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: As he does.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we
changed shirts in the show,
and we just goofed around.
That was a whole lot of fun.
So thanks for
suggesting him, folks,
but we'd love you to suggest
other Googlers that you'd
love to hear from, or
other technologies.
You may not know the
Googler behind it,
but if you're interested
in a Google technology,
we'll find the Googler
behind it and we'll
chat with him over coffee.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
There's a huge playlist
talking with lots of Googlers
on "Coffee with a Googler"
on the Google Developer's
YouTube channel.
Please subscribe.
Don't miss a single episode.
And you've got five new
episodes coming out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: In fact, I
think by the time this airs
two will already be out--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Two of
them will already be out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --and
three more are coming.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So yeah, we
shot some today on Identity.
So we had a couple of episodes
on the Google Identity
platform, including things
like Smart Lock for passwords.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I love Identity
and I love Identity
technologies.
As a developer, good
Identity APIs possibly
have the biggest
impact of any API,
because the amount of
work that developers
will have to do to build
good Identity can be crazy.
So if someone like Google can
provide good Identity APIs,
and we do, it really makes
developers' lives a lot easier.
So I'm a real geek
for that stuff.
So we had a couple
of episodes of that.
We had an awesome episode
on Google Now on Tap.
If you're not familiar
with it, watch the episode.
It's really cool.
And the PM of that, and her
name is actually Paige Rankin,
which, I mean, she's--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's perfect.
LAURENCE MORONEY: She was
born to work for Google.
And she was a fabulous guest,
and she did some great demos.
And I learned a lot
about Google Now on Tap,
And particularly as
a developer, if you
want to take advantage of
this technology, how easy
it is for you to
do so on your apps.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Lots of great
episodes and more on the way.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you, Laurence.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thank you, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And that's
it for our show today.
Please remember to
subscribe to the channel
so you don't miss
a single episode
of "Coffee with a Googler"
or "The Developer Show."
I'd like to thank my
producers, my parents,
my lovely girlfriend, and
of course you, our fans.
Without you, none of
this would be possible.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]